what's up everybody welcome back to the
collider interviews YouTube channel
Perry nemeroff here so this should go
without saying but I'm very excited for
this interview right now because I have
the pleasure of talking with Jeffrey
Reddick who is The Mastermind behind the
Final Destination franchise who is also
here to support his brand new movie
which is due in theaters Nationwide on
August 4th that is till death do us part
congratulations on both things and then
some because you have accomplished way
more beyond that as well thank you so
much Perry I really appreciate you you
all having me on I I I followed collider
um so I stalk you all all the time so
not to be creepy but um it's a pleasure
to be here to talk about
um
everything but especially our the new
film until death do us part which I just
want to say is an indie film everybody
knows we're on strike right now and our
whole production I have my wga support
pin on but I'm also a member of sag so
um our whole production team supports a
strike and hopes that the amptp comes
back to the table to negotiate a fair
deal so that we can all get back to
making our independent films and our
bigger films as well so I am eagerly
awaiting that day both Guild and then
some deserve Fair payment in this
industry and I cannot emphasize that
enough and everybody everybody in this
industry at all levels absolutely needs
to be fairly compensated and it hasn't
happened in a long time but that's one
of the reasons I love working in indie
films is you know like till death do his
part is because when you're doing
interview film you kind of know that you
don't have the budgets that you do for
the big Studio films but I will say that
I this is my third collaboration uh with
Timothy Woodard Jr our director producer
um along with well our third my third
work with ham
um and he just is he's a masterful so I
love his filmmaking first of all he's
one of these people that when he says
I'm going to make a film
I'm like sure okay I'll talk to you in
five years and it's like no it's we're
making it in like three months so I got
him into the horror genre and this is a
really fun action kind of in the vein of
violent night uh kind of movie I think
as far as tonally with like a lot of
humor some over-the-top gore but
grounded and and real characters
um so I think this is going to be a film
that has kind of a wide appeal to people
who want some action
um a lot of action actually Natalie burn
our producer and and our our lead is a
phenomenal she was a ballerina
um which obviously means she knows how
to you know train her body to do all
kinds of crazy uh fighting things but it
also means she's tough as hell when she
she did all of her stunts so um it's it
was really fun to watch
um and on set and the producer side of
me was nervous
um she's also a producer so you know you
gotta you know I didn't get any
arguments with her about it doing her
own stunts because I you know I try I
trust her and I know that we keep
everybody safe on set but I'm like are
you sure we're gonna do that and she's
like yeah I'm like okay there are so
many little things we have to get into
right now I want to kind of like uh pull
back a little in terms of your work as a
producer I got a two-part question in
terms of what you pick to produce
project wise so first more broadly what
signals to you that your own skills and
expertise will benefit a particular
project but then on the other hand when
you read something like till death what
is it about that particular story that
you think would have you know helped you
grow as a producer and filmmaker as well
yeah there are a couple of things I mean
I
I will I will say the project needs to
speak to me on some level
um but usually it's genre stuff
um to be honest
um because I I'm very big on giving back
um to people so I have produced a lot of
just you know independent films that I
know like filmmakers in Kentucky are
doing or in in smaller States I've had
to kind of step back from doing some of
that because
um I I was doing that a lot and um so
now I have to focus more on the the
quality of the the project itself is
also you know because I you know you
want to give back but I I just can't put
my name on everything that somebody
sends me and and produce it for them
um
but I really again it's just my in my
heart about supporting independent
filmmakers but with Timothy we have I
love our story because he was like
hitting me up online a lot and I just
that happens a lot and he's like you
know would you be interested do you have
anything and I was like no I'm you know
a girl you know I can't really and
he's so persistent that's what I love
about him and so finally he sent me some
clips of his work and then I checked it
out I'm like holy crap this guy's like
really good uh so I met him for lunch uh
with my writing Partners on the final
wish which was the a horror film uh the
first one we produced together and
literally like two minutes in I mean I
was kind of sold on him going into the
room but just talking to him and hearing
how passionate he was and the vision he
had in his head and um so with Timothy
if Timothy wants me to produce something
I'm just like yes
um because I know that I know because I
know the quality is going to be good and
I know that he is he makes his stuff
like it's just you know it's crazy
because a lot of times it takes 10 15
years to get something made in this
business and when Timothy is like when
he says he's going to make something he
makes it
um and it turns out good and you know
this just happened to be a happy mixture
of like like I said Violet night kind of
the blood and the action and stuff that
I like but it's Gotta it's got a cool
love story at the center of it that's
you know kind of a love that
unfortunately outside forces are
determined not to make happen
um
and uh yeah so so but but you but
stories that I'm usually drawn to have
some kind of universal appeal to them
and when I did read this I was I did
love the fact that you know it was about
two people who were in love and wanted
to be together but outside forces are
like you can't and
you know unfortunately bloody Mayhem
ensues so um I mean unfortunately but
fortunately for the viewers yes the
audience we need that this Ruby is like
top to bottom ambitious set piece one
after the next so you sign on to produce
you read the script is there any
particular scene that you kind of circle
on the shooting schedule and say to
yourself my God we are going to have our
work cut out for us on that particular
day but then I want to know ultimately
was that indeed the toughest scene or
did something else catch you all by
surprise there wasn't a there weren't a
lot of because again I've worked with
Timothy so much like I I know that he's
gonna pull off stuff
um it's always an ambitious shoot with
with with the projects that we work on
because we don't have the luxury of like
you know
40 50 shooting days 30 sometimes not
even 30 shooting days so it but he's
always got an ambitious Vision in his
mind and he and he always gets to pull
it off
um some of the scenes like
there's just so much fighting in it like
you know I'm like there's a lot of set
pieces that
I'm not you know I hope we don't have to
like shorten these fights
you know and make them really quick just
because we don't have time to shoot them
and we didn't and that was because again
Tim knew what he wanted
Natalie and we harder we hired several
stunt people to play some of the
groomsmen but a lot of the groomsmen
were actors as well
um
yeah you know the the fight with um
Pancho Mueller is one of my my favorite
scenes
um just because it's got humor in it and
Poncho came up with some couple of ideas
for the scene that are that are just fun
they're really funny and but violent and
and he's such a good actor and such a
good sport and and Timothy kind of let
them play so
so I can't there's I'm never because
after working on two movies with Tim
um like at the first film I thought oh
there's these scenes are gonna take it
be hard to pull off and then we did the
call and he came up with even crazier
scenes that we pulled off with less time
than we had I think on the final wish
and then on this one we have a big cast
and you know a lot of the stuff is
centered you know around this Hideaway
for the for the bride but we've got
scenes on a cruise you know this kind of
expensive yacht that's out at Sea
um I know several people I was not there
for that day not on purpose but I know a
lot of people got it got a little
seasick you know because they're out
they're out on sea and this ship is like
pitching
um I would say I don't know Tim would
have to answer that question but I think
that might have been probably the
toughest for them because when you're in
control of everything you can you can
handle all the the variables but I know
on the you know if you're yacht tilts
and things go flying
um and you're seasick that's got to be a
tough thing I I feel bad that I wasn't
there for that because I feel like I
should have been through that that
seasick experience with the rest of the
team that was involved the second you're
saying seasick I'm like oh like no
filmmaking challenges challenge sounds
more challenging than having to deal
with that
absolutely so you've you've brought up
you know there's a bunch of extensive
fight scenes in this movie and also you
do not have like a gigantic Blockbuster
sized uh budget to pull them all off
with and it was making me wonder can you
maybe give us an example of of a
specific uh economical filmmaking tactic
that one can use to pull off action
scenes that maybe more Productions out
there would benefit from learning about
and utilizing yeah well I think part of
making action scenes work is you have to
care about the characters first of all
like especially your protagonist which
is again is Natalie burn so I think you
have a lot of sympathy for her and the
fight scenes in our movie are are brutal
because they're of the intensity of them
I mean you know you don't have to have
people
flying you know driving cars through
walls and you know in a lot of movies
especially because we're used to Marvel
movies it's like you know Iron Man can't
just knock somebody into the air into
the ocean anymore he's got to like fly
them through 20 buildings that have to
crumble you know like so there's the
spectacle of that but when you when you
have a movie with a character that you
care about and also you know the
groomsmen that are that are you know her
kind of main Nemesis
um when you have these fight scenes
between people that know each other and
they're they're brutal in their
intensity and that you know there's no
holding back you know obviously
you know it's there's something that's
why they have a lot of female horror
leads as well there's something about
having a female in danger that gets us
on a visceral level and we certainly you
know don't want to see a woman getting
like beat with a crap beat out ever but
this is like a fight for survival movie
and
so watching two human beings like Pummel
each other and kick each other and in
the ribs and like every hit counts you
know and that that's also a mixture of
sound effects you know stunt work but
also you know some of the sometimes they
were they took a punch you know and so I
think that that intensity
um it doesn't have to be on a big scale
if it if you're really feeling it
um especially between characters that
know each other and also when it if it's
characters that love each other but it's
like this only one of us is the old only
one of us is getting out of here alive
kind of situation the stakes of it are
what make it really impactful I think
with with action set pieces like that oh
absolutely it's not you know it doesn't
matter how big the punch is as long as
it feels visceral in the end
you're like oh and there's a there's
again there's a couple of kills that are
just like they're ah like viscerally but
then it'll go it'll go next level over
where it kind of makes it fun you know
um none of it's fun it's horrible
murdering people in real life I always
have to clarify that when I talk about
fun murdering people oh but with every
single project you work on I imagine
you'll have to discover yeah yeah I do
not condone murdering people or hurting
people on
I love watching it
because when it's done in a like one of
the things I think Tim brings to this
film in all of his films is there's a
sense of humor to it but not like
goofball Three Stooges kind of humor
like there's there's levity within the
violence as well
um and you do get little little breaks
at certain points and then there are
points where you just don't get breaks
where it's just like you know she is
like going groomsmen after groomsmen
after groom's been and it's like yeah
it's just that it's that intensity that
emotional connection I think that that
filmmakers
and a lot of them get it like you see a
lot of independent films where they do a
great job with this where they realize
it is the intensity within the scene
um and it's not about having super big
explosions happening behind your
characters while they're fighting I mean
yeah it looks cool again from Marvel
movies or fast acts like if you want to
have a car jump off a bridge and then
ride down a dam and then fly yeah do all
kinds of you know go into space or
whatever but
um there's I love that stuff too it's
crazy and Fantastical but this stuff is
more grounded and I think the more
grounded
set pieces even like in a Die Hard movie
the first one especially was very you
know they had effects
um but it really was you know Bruce
Willis taking on the people that were
holding that build a building hostage
and now I'm trying to protect his wife
and that was that made every fight it
made the stakes behind the fight so
important and the stakes behind every
fight in this movie are important
absolutely
all right I'm gonna remind everybody
till death do us part is in theaters on
August 4th now I'm going to do the thing
that I specifically asked permission for
I wanted to make sure it was okay I'm
gonna switch and highlight some of your
work on the Final Destination film
franchise which as I told you before we
went uh not live but before we started
recording that franchise is near and
dear to my heart I credit it with being
one of the big reasons why I work in
this industry in this capacity why I'm a
horror lover first and foremost so the
first thing I wanted to ask you about
with that one is I do I know about the
article that first inspired the Final
Destination concept but just to give our
audience the lay of the land here can
you explain to them what that article
was yeah it was an article I was flying
home to Kentucky and I read an article
about a woman who was on a flight and
her she was in Hawaii I think and her
mom said don't call her and said don't
take the flight you're on tomorrow I
have bad feeling about it so she
switched flights and the plane that she
was supposed to be on
crashed and so that put the idea in my
head
um which is interesting because what
struck me about that is it it made me
think about premonitions in a way but it
also made me because I because I I do
believe that that you know I do believe
there are people out there that have
gifts you know like whether it's psychic
kind of gifts or whatever
um I have I've never been able to
levitate I've tried it
um after reading X-Men I tried it for
many times and failed but I do believe
that people have kind of gifts and I do
believe in fate you know like I I know
from a young age my dream was to be in
this business and that was inspired that
I love that
Final Destination inspired you
um
indie film that inspired me was a
nightmare on Elm Street
um it actually I credit that whole movie
with my career which is again why I'm
such a big supporter of Indie filmmaking
but that movie got me in touch with Bob
Shea who ran new line Cinema which was
like the biggest kind of independent
film studio at the time Nightmare made
it a studio
um and I ended up working there and it
was just it was it was determination on
my end but it was fade also that Bob
responded to me when I was like this 14
year old kid from Kentucky who had no
idea how the film business worked and I
pestered him until he read a prequel
idea that I'd written for that film and
I worked there for 11 years
um and his assistant Joy man who isn't
with us any longer was like you know
like a godmother to me I mean she took
me under her wings at 14. I would call
her collect because I didn't know that
was not a cool thing to do as a 14 year
old in Kentucky
um and you know that's why I think this
this industry it's like
you know I'm a huge genre fan like 90 of
the stuff I do is in in the genre I did
work in animation and I started doing
that in covid which I which I love as
well
um I just because I love writing but um
oh I saw your cat and I was waiting for
my cat to come up behind me I thought it
was my cat because it's right in the
corner I was like
this is Malcolm hey Malcolm
um my cat's named Damien very
appropriate she's a little devil that's
why
um
so yeah you know the Final Destination
thing evolved
um and I love telling the story because
if people have this weird idea about how
the industry works and it it was 10
years from the day that I graduated high
school that I sold
the treatment for Final Destination but
then I had to rework it so much
um before a new line even bought it and
then it got reworked a lot
um for the better I love how the film
turned out by James Wong and Lynn Morgan
who came on to write and direct it and
that's what people don't understand a
lot of times about the business is it's
so hard to even get a movie made but
there are so many steps that it takes to
make it happen that it can not happen at
any point so you know writers only get
paid if the movie gets made and goes in
a profit and luckily they did Final
Destination through the guild if they
hadn't done it through the guild I would
probably not have seen I probably
wouldn't have seen any money from it
after the first one came out and I wrote
the story for the second one as well
um uh which was great but it's a
franchise that's near and dear to my
heart you know as a horror fan
just yeah I'm rambling I should let you
ask your questions because I'm telling
you all this I would sit here and listen
to like a whole oral history of your
entire experience along with this
franchise I I wanted to go straight to
Final Destination too with that comment
but first specifically with the first
one I am curious can you highlight maybe
uh a particular actor who did something
with what the role was on the page that
just kind of blew your mind and that
character became more than you ever
could have anticipated I mean obviously
uh well I shouldn't say Obviously but
Devin sour you know playing Alex
um I intentionally wanted to have a
final guy for that movie because I again
I wanted to turn just the convention on
its head and
um when I watched that performance even
today I mean
when he throughout the movie he's
amazing but that premonition scene and
the way that he plays it and the fear
that's that he has after he comes out of
that premonition through the plane
exploding spoiler alert if you haven't
watched it shame on you
um
he is so good like he gives one of the I
mean that performance Rivals any
performance I've seen in a horror movie
and you know in horror movies a lot of
times you know guys don't get to play
that role at the you know we're at the
beginning I mean he's he's nervous
through up until the flight but his
performance during the premonition scene
and after just rivets me and I'm like
because there's just so many emotions
that go through his face
um and he's amazing throughout the film
it's one of my
I love all you know my films even the
ones that didn't turn out so great you
find something to love about all your
stuff because I I think you have to stay
in gratitude or you just won't make it
in this business but Devin and I'm
friends with him to this day and and I
but I I will go back and just watch
that scene I mean I've seen the movie a
zillion times but I will go back and
watch that scene because his performance
is so
amaz like that performance in that scene
is is definitely my favorite makes me
happy that you've watched it a million
times I feel like I've spoken to so many
filmmakers who like I know you have to
watch it a lot while you're actually
working on the film but so many after
like okay I've watched it that many
times and now I'm kind of stepping away
from it well I watch it it's comfort
food I mean I've been in the business
for like 30 I know I don't like it but
for over 30 years and so I watch it
sometimes as comfort food but then if I
go to conventions
or speak at school panels sometimes
they'll show it at schools colleges
though I don't wanna where are those
scores
in trouble yeah Galilean college but you
know so anytime I go anywhere they want
to show it of course I'm going to say
yes because if it weren't for
the fans of the franchise we wouldn't
have a franchise so um and we do it
there is a sixth one that's planned the
minute I mean again the amptp comes back
to the table that movie is ready to
ready to go so
um it's just really it's it's just nice
as a genre fan to have
something created that has
become a part of the public Zeitgeist
you know it's just you know again I
couldn't have asked for more I am a big
fan of the uh the filmmakers you all
recruited to direct that sixth film as
though I didn't have enough faith in
that franchise the two the two of them
in particular I'm like I know I know
we're gonna get another winner here
we're gonna get a winner and also I
spoke to
um Guy music he did this scream reboot
and um Stephanie is his writing partner
and they were so gracious because
they you know they actually you know I'm
friends with Craig Perry to this day
like we're really tight who produced it
and he's like they called me they wanted
to talk to me about
the first film and the second film about
what I what my thoughts were on what
makes a final destination film like the
kind of the key elements that are
crucial to me and um it's just really
nice because you don't get that a lot
like I'm friends with you know Eric
brass from who wrote part two like you
know you you become friends a lot of
times with people just crossing paths
um and Eric who wrote part five is
amazing but it's it's nice when the
filmmakers actually call you and they're
like you know what's in you know we want
to make sure that we get the essence of
what's important to you and what you
think makes us these final destinations
what you found make connects with the
fans so they have gone into the story
with the you know the best hard and then
John Watt who was behind the Spider-Man
yeah you know new movies came up with a
story so I mean I was just like this is
like the a team like I am I I am
just like Craig will tell me stuff and
and I can't repeat it obviously
um because I'm very good at that because
I know I know I don't want to spoil
anything but you know every time that
I've heard anything that's going that
they're doing or any scene that they're
doing or planning it just makes me smile
like the fans are going to be it's going
to be well worth the wait for the fans I
don't want to ask you to spoil anything
but I did want to ask you about one
thing that I've read that you said in
the past that this new movie is not
going to uh follow the established
formula like roughly how much is it
gonna Veer away from from desk design or
maybe add another layer like the past
films have you know what I think it's
when I say stairway it's not gonna
I love all the films and I think that
you can't get away from the cheating
death and death coming after you part of
it because that's what makes it a final
destination film and I think the Rube
Goldberg device which actually James
Wong and Glenn Morgan came up with I
have to give them total props for that
because I'm in a huge nightmare and Elm
Street fan and my original script was
very nightmare down the street
influenced reality bending kind of ways
that death got to them
um but this film doesn't just kind of
add another layer like usually there's a
new layer every film where it's like oh
well this can save you or this can save
you this film dives into the film in
such a unique way that it just it takes
it it attacks it from a different angle
so you don't feel like oh there's an
amazing setup
and then there's there's going to be one
wrinkle that can potentially save you
all that you you have to kind of make a
moral choice about or do to to solve it
so there's there's a
expansion of the universe
that
um I'm speaking so careful I respect
that there's there's this expansion of
the the world of Final Destination that
I think fans are going to be
really interested in and intrigued by
because it it does it
it does when I say it doesn't add a
layer it's not just hey if you murder
somebody in your place you'll live
um there's a there's a it kind of
unearths a whole like deep layer to the
story that kind of
yes makes it really really interesting
this is solid tease I'm here for any
Final Destination but in particular
after hearing something like that now I
need to know how the mythology is going
to grow I've kept you a few minutes too
long so if you need the bolt I
understand
I I'm fine
um yeah I'm absolutely fine
um I'll throw I'll throw a couple a
couple more of my my fan obsessive
questions at you right now because I
know I know you've said in the past that
Final Destination 2 went through less of
an evolution from script to screen than
Final Destination one did so it was
making me wonder is there anything that
you originally had planned for Final
Destination one that you know got bumped
out of that film but you were able to
embrace more heavily when you were
working on the story but the second film
nothing real the because again I think
the the biggest thing that changed for
the film this story is basically the
same but in my version because again of
my nightmare Elm Street influence
because death
messed up the first time it couldn't
come back and just kill them again so
um we never saw death but it was very it
would psychologically manipulate
survivor's guilt or something that the
kids had done
um to make them kill themselves in ways
that look like accidents which is pretty
heavy
um so I actually did recycle some of the
death scenes from that script in my
movie Tamara
um so I got to I got to use the
psychological
um
you know kind of either sins of the kids
or secrets of the kids being used to to
off them I I did I did crib several
scenes from that and put it in my movie
Tamara but once we got to Final
Destination 2 I kind of knew what the
that the Rube Goldberg aspect was the
way to go
um so when I came up with a story for
that and the you know the opening with
the log truck scene
um you know I got to I just went with
the Rube Goldberg aspect and a couple
things I wanted to do with the sequel
that I love with sequels is I wanted to
start off with because in the first
movie originally they my treatment they
were all adults but then scream came out
and I love screaming Kevin Williams is a
good friend of mine too and yeah I'm not
dropping names I'm just saying when I
talk about movies it's like you know
it's a tight community so we we all get
to know each other
um over the years uh but we they changed
it to all teenagers
um so what I wanted to do with the
second one was open up on a group of
teenagers that you think are going to be
oh this is these are going to be our
teenagers that are the lead characters
and then
wipe most of them out except for AJ
Cook's character Kimberly
um in the First Act and then we follow
adults so I brought I got to carry that
over into the sequel
um and and I also wanted to expand the
mythology so that you learn that the
characters all their Fates in the second
movie were tied to the face of the
character in the first movie
um that's why they were on that freeway
that day
um and I got to bring you know some
original characters back I wanted to
bring both Alex and clear back
um there were some issues with
scheduling and stuff with with getting
Devin Sauer back and I got annoyed how
you know they just killed him off with a
brick which I thought was a big Fu
um that's the only that's really my only
complaint with Final Destination too and
to be honest if I had them both back I
had always planned on killing Kimberly I
mean I mean clear but I wanted to keep
Alex alive to you know there I had a
cold twist at the end where it still was
you know she has a life that saves her
life
um
but then death gets her once she has the
has the the kid and Alex is still kind
of the torch Bearer that was my original
take but with the scheduling stuff we
ended up with no Alex and I'm like oh if
I didn't know we weren't going to bring
Alex back I would have not have killed
clear because I I love bringing original
people back but I don't like killing
them
get that oh I love I love the franchise
so much as is but like see hearing that
like alt path that could have gone down
is very curious to me can can I ask you
do you mind why you're not an executive
producer on three four and five yeah I
was an executive producer on the second
one uh because they use my story really
and you know I I was I was involved a
lot behind the scenes on the first film
because I worked at the studio uh but I
you know at that point I was I was
working at the studio till I sold the
second movie
um and finally they were like Jeffrey we
love you you've been here 11 years
you have two Studio films coming out now
you're a big boy writer so you probably
should go be a big boy Rider and quit
working here in our marketing and TV
Department I'm like okay
um
so there's no real reason honestly I
feel they I mean I still stay involved
especially through through Craig but
it is and I and I think it's partially
because I worked at the studio for so
long I there was definitely two things
happened I didn't move to LA after I
sold the first one which I should have
done you know I in hindsight as a
creative I should have moved out here so
I could take meetings and people would
know me
um you know James Wong and Glenn Morgan
were out here so they got you know we're
taking all the meetings and so by the
time I moved out here people were you
know my agent's like well I know that
you worked on the the first two movies
but you know in Hollywood it's like
really the directors and the stars that
get all the meetings and so I kind of
have to reintroduce you to the town so I
feel like there's this undercurrent at
new line if I'm being honest that I'm an
employee that got lucky for them because
I worked there for so long as opposed to
thinking oh wow he's a screenwriter who
created a big franchise for us so again
it's that's the way the business that's
you know it's perception I I don't get
bitter because honestly
I feel like with especially you know
with the first two films and the log
truck scene in the second one like both
of those scenes came from me going home
to Kentucky came to me and the log truck
seemed as kind of probably the most
iconic scene from the franchise
um as a horror fan I'm I always stay in
gratitude about stuff but I it was funny
when I was talking to Craig recently I
was like you know what yeah if we do I
know it's been 13 years
um since there's been a final next year
I know so I did tell Craig this a lot
when we were talking like the last time
I was like yeah when you all do a next
one like you know I want to come in and
talk to you because you know there was a
point of me where I'm like yeah I'll let
him come to me I'll just keep doing a
you know I'll keep doing my my thing
because I'm very proud of it and I do
feel like they brought in great people
to do the sequels so
again like I'm not so precious about
something where it like it has to be me
or you know I you know
um you know I loved what Eric press and
J Mackey Gruber and David Ellis did with
the the second one and you know
the yeah I just like all of them and I I
think they keep bringing in great people
to do it so I feel like it's like
you know this is a baby that I put out
in the world and other people are taking
care of it now as it grows up
but well that sounds awful
um I feel like I put a baby in the world
and then it turned
um it turned legal
and then other people are taking care of
it it's yeah poor yeah give birth to a
baby and just pass it around that
doesn't sound I will say though
regardless of the title I feel like I
know I could speak for myself but it
also does feel like I could speak for
some of the Final Destination fan base
that you are very clearly viewed as like
the Godfather of this franchise and I
feel like when it comes to the fan
perspective that that's what matters
more than anything in the world it does
and it and it took a while it took a
while you know because I like I said my
agent said when I came out here he's
like we're gonna have to kind of
reintroduce you to the town and I was
like but my name's all over the poster
and it says my story and you know and I
get a screenplay and he's like yeah but
they uh you know the business sees who
walks through their door you know they
don't look at the credits and things
like that so
um so yes it's absolutely
the fan base knows and in Hollywood
knows now it just took it took some time
um but I'm again I'm just grateful
because I I've always said like as a
little kid like that 14 year old kid in
Hollywood or in Kentucky if you'd have
told him one day he would create a
franchise that would
would be because you know it's it's
mentioned up there with like really
amazing iconic franchises from that era
and before and after like I would be
like oh that would be sweet and that's
what I that's what I'm like I still want
to do a couple more you know it's you
know but
yeah that if that's on my Tombstone I
will be very happy but I love I love
that I've expanded again into producing
and directing and but the producing part
is really fun because again
I get a chance to meet filmmakers like
Timothy and work on you know horror
films with him like again he's he'll he
this isn't a horror film till death do
us part it's it's action again in the
vein of violent night but more action
not as not as horror but I got him
hooked on horror so then it's like all
right I got another one so I can keep
you know spread the horror love out
there and now he's a horror fan too so
um I'm a big fan of that happening oh so
this this makes me think of I'll end
with this question here because speaking
of you know spreading the horror love
one of final destination's claim to fame
is that many people out there won't do
certain things anymore because of the
kill scenes that happen in these movies
so is there any particular thing that
happens in one of these films that has
changed your own day to day oh that's a
good question
um
no the only funny because I never liked
log trucks like that's what I you know
when when I was trying to come up with
the opening for the second one I got
behind one and that I immediately pulled
over and then I was like ah crap and
then I pulled off the highway and called
Craig and he's like that's the opening
because we'd been trying to figure out
like he didn't like some of the other
openings that he's like it's just not
big enough
um but I will say because I I've never
had a fear of flying but I will say if I
get on a plane and there's any
turbulence
I won't freak out but I'll be like you
know what this will just be my luck like
that this plane goes down
and that's gonna be like
it'll be great for marketing the next
one
would you ever get on a flight if the
number was 180. I think about this a lot
and I think I probably would just
because I'd be so curious like I would
feel I would feel like it was fate that
I was given a flight with that number
and I'm so obsessed with this franchise
yeah that's how I would look at it as
well so so I haven't I haven't nothing's
been shown that I that's made me
afraid of something that I wasn't afraid
of already like
like gymnastics I would never do because
I'd be afraid I'd fall off a bar and
break my you know so but so it's no it
hasn't it hasn't traumatized with
anything but I think that's being a
horror fan and knowing that you know
behind the scenes of these movies
are what you see on the screen like when
you when you're shooting it like
the fight scenes until death was part
like what you see on the screen great
but there were also you know people like
right off camera with with lights and
you know
and and sound people and when you have
like romantic or sexual scenes in films
yeah it looks sexy on screen but you if
you were to pull back you'd see you know
light in rip people like holding their
cameras like yawning like how many takes
is this so
um he said yeah I haven't I haven't
really I do think the gymnastics scene
in the fifth one was
the scene that um
shocked me the most
where I actually
yelled out during this they're in the
screening the early screening of it I
was kind of embarrassed because I'm so
used to these movies that the way that
that scene ended I was like ah like it
really it I give major props to
everybody involved in that wood because
that that scene actually did make me
scream out loud in the theater I feel
like that's the ultimate achievement to
get you of all people to actually scream
out loud with one of those I could I
could seriously keep you here all day
talking about this particular franchise
I will say congratulations on that and
and all of the the horror that you have
infused this world with because as weird
as it sounds the horror you have created
makes me happy but also congratulations
on what you're doing as a producer in
terms of uh you know supporting
independent cinema within the genre and
then also really pumping up emerging
voices in this space because if people
like you don't do that there's so many
wonderful horror filmmakers out there
that would not get the time in the
spotlight they deserve so thank you and
congratulations on all of that thank you
so much it was great talking with you
and um yeah we can always come back and
talk about about have a gabathon on
Final Destination but but everybody
should go out yes uh support indie film
and check out till death do this part
and it's going to be in AMC's I know but
some other theaters as well on August
4th and again Timothy's all he's a he's
in a you know like let's keep him in
genre stuff because he does westerns he
does all kinds of films like let's let's
just keep him in doing the horror genre
stuff because um he's good he's really
good at it he's a great keeping him in
horror we could do we could do a genre
mashup movie too we've got we've got
action and horror let's do it let's do a
horror Western next yeah you know what
he'll hear this and I bet you I bet you
that will come into fruition someday
very soon